if you're jumping into the Ghost Recon  wildlands beta this weekend you can grab  a few special rewards I'm Tony and this  is your unlocked gamespot news update  playing the wildlands beta will unlock a  number of cosmetic items including gun  skins a backpack and clothing and  accessories for your ghosts playing the  beta is the only way to get the goofy  llama t-shirt but other rewards will be  available on you play when the full game  launches to unlock these goodies all you  have to do is complete simple tasks with  the game's Ghost Recon network like  logging in completing your profile and  starting a chat seems like a good way to  kick off your full campaign next month  Ghost Recon wildlands hits ps4 xbox one  and pc on march 7th we recently got our  hands on the game and discussed how it  compares to the division on the lobby  gamespot's weekly live show so give that  a watch then stay tuned to gamespot for  all the latest on ghost recon see you in  the beta soldier